it's no secret that super mario 64
revolutionized the video game industry
and fundamentally changed the way we
play games with the recent release of
super mario 3d all-stars many gamers
could be playing for the first time
others may still be on the fence asking
does super mario 64
still hold up in 2020 that's our topic
for today's video
people of the internet retrorecontour
here if we're meeting for the first time
i'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they
tell we post videos twice a week here on
youtube and today we're talking all
about super mario 64 and how well it
holds up here in the year 2020.
should you play it if you have never
experienced it before i hope to answer
that question
and maybe a few more here in today's
video
many gamers my age are re-living their
childhood right now as three
classic mario games have taken the
spotlight once again thanks to the
recent release of super mario 3d
all-stars
and we have the younger gamers out there
like my son who were checking out 64
sunshine and galaxy for the very first
time there's no denying that for its
time super mario 64 was an absolute
masterpiece
when it released in 1996 alongside
nintendo's new console
the nintendo 64 gamers were absolutely
blown away to see the italian plumber in
3d for the first time
trust me i was there if you're a younger
gamer out there or maybe an older gamer
who didn't play games as a kid
just try and put yourselves in the mind
of a gamer back in 1996.
for starters a third-person 3d
perspective is something we've never
experienced before most games on home
consoles were side scrollers like the
original super mario brothers
of course you also had games with a top
down view like the original legend of
zelda
over on pc you had shooters like
wolfenstein 3d and doom experimenting
with first person perspectives
so going back and playing super mario 64
now
here in 2020 is a fascinating experience
i recently started playing through it
again over on my twitch stream which
by the way i'd love to have you guys
stop by and check out sometime if you're
interested
right now we stream on monday and
wednesday evenings
i'll throw a link down in the
description below but as for mario 64 i
was immediately struck by
how many of the game mechanics are still
being used today
in numerous third-person games i mean
there's actually a giant
see-saw-like structure early in the game
that immediately reminded me of this
summer smash hit fall guys
even something as simple as the ability
to walk directly up to a sign or an npc
and interact with him in 3d was
something we had never experienced
before and now it's just a given in a
third person game something you just
don't even think about
in the days of the nes and snes nintendo
was known for their incredible level
design
that certainly carried over to mario 64
and still holds up
today peach's castle acts as a hub world
while paintings throughout the castle
transport you to world with completely
different aesthetics
from snow to underwater to lava all the
classics
they're there not to mention all the
secrets you can discover in
and around peach's castle yet again it's
just
incredible how many of the ideas here
still carry over into our games today
at this point you may be thinking oh
this sounds great you should know though
there are some frustrations with mario
64 and some clear
examples where it shows its age the most
obvious one would be the camera
nintendo certainly had the right idea
for controlling the character with the
analog stick which is still the primary
form of movement for console gamers to
this day
what they weren't quite able to figure
out back then was the camera
you see the n64 controller had only one
analog stick instead of a second stick
the controller had a series of four
directional buttons on the right side of
the controller these were originally
intended to be used for camera control
which is what mario 64 did
now even though both the joy cons and
the switch pro controller have two
analog sticks the right analog stick
still behaves in a way that is
essentially just four buttons
left right up and down you don't have
full 360 degree control
over the camera here's a little tip if
you're having trouble with the camera
try not
moving the camera so much like you would
in a modern third-person game with full
camera control
instead let it do its thing most of the
time and simply adjust
how you're moving mario in time you'll
get more comfortable having to move
mario in directions other than just
straight ahead now if you're playing
super mario 64 for the first time thanks
to super mario 3d all-stars go ahead and
leave me a comment down below let me
know what you guys think so far
it's not only the camera though that's a
little wonky even moving mario can feel
strange at first
although an analog stick was certainly
the right call to control mario it's not
as responsive as i remember
it could be because mario odyssey is
fresh in my mind
in fact if you've played odyssey
recently you'll instantly notice the
stark difference here
odyssey's movement controls are precise
and sharp whereas 64's controls feel a
little loose
almost delayed slightly and nowhere near
as sharp
truth be told i expected the control
issues and i have to admit it's
certainly something you get more
comfortable with as you play
the issue that surprised me the most
though the difficulty
super mario 64 is actually a lot harder
than i remember
at least if you're going for all the
stars i'm sure a quick play through
would be a lot easier but my son has had
a difficult time getting into 64 and
while he's only six
he's practically an expert at super
mario odyssey seriously he has over 700
moons
all by himself don't get me wrong some
stars are absurdly easy but others will
have you banging your head against the
wall when you can't get the controls
just right
there's one particular star early in the
game where you have to use the wall jump
for the first time
and i don't know man there's just
something weird about the responsiveness
of the wall jump in this game it doesn't
always work the way i think it should in
my head
it definitely doesn't work the way that
modern wall jumps do in current mario
games
there's also this weird issue where you
can't seem to back out of a level
but pro tip just stop moving mario
and then pause the game seriously it's
so strange but if you're moving mario
and pause the game you won't be able to
leave the level
if you stop moving though and then pause
you'll have the option to exit
so where do i come down on our question
that we open the video with does super
mario
64 still hold up in 2020.
absolutely positively yes
are there some frustrations that you'll
have to overlook in your quest to beat
the game or go after all 120 stars
absolutely positively yes but just from
a simple standpoint of being a fan of
video games you owe it to yourself to
play one of the defining games in the
history of the medium
trust me guys you will be amazed as you
notice numerous little details and
gameplay design choices that still
to this day impact our games in 2020 and
i'm sure beyond
playing super mario 64 also gives me a
completely new
appreciation for super mario odyssey
which is an absolutely
brilliant evolution it still has all the
dna of mario 64 everywhere you look
honestly looking back at all the 3d
mario games you can see their steady
improvement with each generation but all
the while maintaining the spirit of the
original
that started it all now if you guys want
to get your hands on super mario 3d
all-stars check my link
in the description below and remember
nintendo is for some inexplicable reason
making this game only available for a
limited time
it's annoying it's frustrating let
nintendo know about it if you don't want
to buy the game because of it
don't now if you can't get a physical
copy at the link below you can always go
for a digital version straight from
nintendo as well
once again i have to thank you guys for
all the support you've been showing the
channel lately if you're new here and
you're not yet subscribed please
consider hitting that subscribe button
and don't forget to ring the bell so you
won't miss any of our new videos
a thumbs up always helps as well and as
always thank you so much for watching
today's video
i'll talk to you again soon